Second question today.
Hey David, does Trump win by making the squad
the face or faces of the Democratic Party?
I actually disagree with the premise of the
question.
I don't believe that Donald Trump is making
those four ethnic minority congresswoman that
he attacked, which such xenophobic phobic
ideas as they should go back to their original
countries.
They still have relatively low name recognition
nationally outside of their districts and
it's really, I know it's hard for people who
do politics every week like we do or people
who follow politics.
Like many of you in the audience to understand
this, these four congress women are not very
well known to the American public.
My guess is AOC is more well known than the
others.
Certainly.
Uh, but outside of political circles, these
are still individuals who have relatively
low a name recognition or face recognition.
They're also, you know, we've talked about
the popularity thing.
They're not hugely popular.
They're not unpopular, particularly the way
Donald Trump tried to make them seem on the
basis of polling of non college educated whites,
big shock or non college educated whites don't
love Alexandra Casteo, Cortez, Ilana, Omar,
I, Anna Presley, and the fourth one I'm Rashida
to leave.
But they're not particularly unpopular or
particularly popular is the truth.
And what you also have to understand is that
Donald Trump's approval is, is highest.
It does best when he's altogether silent.
And these four members of Congress are keeping
Donald Trump fired up.
They are keeping him going nuts.
They're continuing to push him to put just
ridiculous things on Twitter that yes, his
own base is probably unaffected by, but independence
and people who are sort of influential, uh,
influenceable reachable, uh, don't particularly
like it when Donald Trump goes on these tirades
specifically attacking people.
So what Trump wins, uh, is not, let me step
back.
This doesn't mean that focusing on these four
democratic congressmen, women isn't good for
trumping other ways.
Okay.
I just disagree that he's making them the
face of the Democratic Party.
The wind for Trump in calling these four women
out in talking about them and focusing on
them is that he helps to divide the left and
when you play up those divisions, when you
make those divisions appear bigger than they
are.
Uh, that is why we need to be careful about
this because that is not good for the Democratic
Party.
Trump appearing to take a side in the squad
versus Nancy Pelosi to the extent that that's
even really a thing.
It's good for Trump.
It's bad for Democrats.
Any political capital, time and media time
that between now and November of 2020 is spent
on internal fighting within the left is good
for Trump.
And this is why I said at the beginning of
the week on the topic of impeachment, Democrats
need to just agree, we're not going to do
an impeachment inquiry and we're not going
to talk about it anymore.
Or we're going to do one in like six months,
because that's when it will be most damaging
to Donald Trump.
Or we're going to do one right now and they
need to actually say out loud.
If we keep doing this publicly where I say,
I want an inquiry, and you say you don't,
and you say you do, and the media cycle continues,
this is not good for our chances to remove
Donald Trump in November of 2020.
That is how Trump wins.
By playing up the squad controversy, he's
not really making them the face of the Democratic
Party.
And these are still relative unknowns to nonpolitical,
average Joe and Jane Doe, Joe and Jane Schmoe
in the dough, it implies, I think that they're
dead.
Uh, Joe Schmoe, not doe, uh, in the United
States.
If you disagree with me, change my mind.